good afternoon everyone this is such a
wonderful uh
audience and it's really quite a thrill
and an honor to be here to welcome
Anderson Cooper as our
2023 spring chub fellow
my name is Mary Lou I am the head of
college for Timothy Dwight college and
it is truly
oh
thank you TD it's always
[Applause]
[Music]
we might have tipped the scales a little
bit
so before we begin today's conversation
with Anderson Cooper I'm just going to
ask that all of you turn off your cell
phones and refrain from taking any
photographs while the program is going
I would also like to start our program
with a land acknowledgment today's Chubb
Fellowship event sits on traditional
indigenous territories this includes
lands of the Mohegan the Mohican the
Mashantucket Pequot Eastern Pequot
Chicago
Niantic Quinnipiac and other Algonquin
speaking peoples we honor and pay
respect to their peoples of past and
present
as I said my name is Mary Lou I'm the
head of college of Timothy Dwight
College I'm a professor in the
department of history and the program in
American studies I also have the great
honor of being the custodian of the
Chubb Fellowship
and I want to give you a little bit
information and background about the
chub before we begin established in 1941
the Chubb Fellowship came out of a large
donation for quote unquote education
purposes made in 1936 by Hendon Chubb a
graduate of the Yale class of 1895.
since its establishment the Chubb fund
has adhered to the goals of providing
encouragement and Aid to students
interested in government and American
public affairs the fellowship initially
aimed to Foster among Yale
undergraduates an interest in public
service in local and state affairs grew
over the years to include numerous
distinguished visitors in National and
international Affairs as well as leaders
in the world of the Arts and Humanities
since the 1940s the Chubb Fellowship
lecture Series has inspired generations
of Yale students to undertake public
service and pursue leadership roles in
the hopes of creating a better world
today and for posterity
the fellowship has hosted four U.S
presidents George H.W bush Gerald Ford
Jimmy Carter and Harry Truman in recent
years we have welcomed a wide range of
national and international leaders
including our congressional
representative The Honorable Rosa de
lauro violin Virtua so Hillary Hahn
highly decorated Olympic figure skater
Michelle Kwan visual artist Faith
Ringgold environmental activist Bill
McKibben Somali physician and
humanitarian Dr Hawa Abdi and so many
more so with this quick description of
the history and aims of the Chubb
Fellowship I'm deeply honored to have
Anderson Cooper join the impressive list
of chub fellows who have visited Timothy
Dwight College in Yale's campus
so welcome Anderson
and now I want to Welcome to the stage
James Jimmy hatch to introduce Anderson
Cooper fully and properly
come on up
[Applause]
thanks Mary thanks everybody for who
clapped I don't know why you would do
that but whatever I know everybody wants
to hear Anderson so I'm going to make
this quick but I think it's important I
met Anderson when he interviewed me in
uh I think it was 2015 and uh he made
quite an impact on me I'd seen him on
television and I'd seen him do some
things that to me were rather impressive
and I'll get to those in a second first
thing I want to do is read
um so you get to know him
say this is not unlike Anderson he fixed
my tie once in an interview
get it together Mary
so um before his late mother passed he
and she wrote this book and I found this
part of it really beautiful knowing
Anderson a little bit so I'm just going
to read her description
to quote Elizabeth Browning I love you
in ways that are infinite and as in
eternity have no beginning or end but
are we alike and again this is his
mother speaking sometimes I think hardly
at all you are the living image of your
father not only in appearance but in
valuing the same standards he held in
high regard standards that are sometimes
hard to live by other times yes we are
indeed completely alike we share
sensitivity tempered by Poise and the
reserve to reveal only what we wish to
communicate we have the gift of editing
presenting ourselves in different ways
to different people we are not gossips
we are worthy to be trusted with secrets
of families and family and friends we
have fun going to the movies together
sharing a bag of popcorn we do not
burden each other with trivial troubles
or pull each other down with
unsupportive comments
we advise each other on pressing matters
from time to time and you always give me
a short sensible well-thought-out
solution to any problem
I try to respond in the same manner we
both spend a lot of time organizing our
lives secretly working out various
options and scenarios in our heads
luckily yours are far more practical and
more likely to become reality than mine
which continue to be influenced by the
enchanted fairy tales I read as a child
in spite of this I treasure those fairy
tales for
they are in large part what spur my
creativity
we share a Restless spirit in fact we
are never at rest and rarely if ever
will anything satisfy Andy and his mom
soon something beckons it's there around
the corner just out of sight all we need
to do is follow
all my life I have craved and longed for
love and I have not been deprived my cup
hath runeth over but it was never enough
it never got anywhere near what the
trouble really was no mother no father
as my secret sister Susan Sontag Knew
Too Well here Andy thankfully we are not
alike even though you lost your father
when you were 10 you knew that there
wasn't a moment from birth when you
didn't have and know his support how
fully completely he loved you and Carter
although only those years were given
they were enough for him to pass on to
you the values that have made you the
person that you are my son treasured
each moment of my life
I don't think you can get much better
than that
now as for me personally
I remember watching
um
I was in the SEAL Teams and in the SEAL
Teams people like Anderson journalists
are essentially the same as any other
enemy we have so I was I was a rather I
was rather harsh on journalists but I
remember watching it was in the early
90s and I've discussed this with one of
Anderson's camera guys Neil they were in
Haiti and it was there were some
troubles there often there are troubles
in Haiti but Anderson was standing at an
intersection and he was on camera I was
watching him and I think I was actually
overseas somewhere when I was watching
it and
he's talking and all of a sudden you can
see on the buildings behind him
rocks and other projectiles hitting them
and it was getting ugly quick and
Anderson immediately turned and grabbed
this kid threw him under his arm and
started running out of the intersection
and I thought to myself man you know
that's something you're either born with
or not you can't train somebody to do
that to be that thoughtful in the middle
of emergency situation like that to grab
someone who can't be protected and get
him out of there
so that was my that he became less of an
enemy at that point to me
and then I was in New York after
Anderson and I had gotten to be a little
bit closer I was in New York for
um another function and I went to the
CNN Studios and it happened to be the
same time that the Pulse Nightclub
shooting had gone down so Anderson was
in Orlando
and I was in the production room it's
really cool to see how the the sausages
made so to speak how busy people are and
Anderson was down there and he was
reporting on the shooting and then they
went to a commercial and during the
commercial Anderson had a long uh piece
of paper and he was reading off names
and there was one of the producers in
the booth was helping him so that he
could say the names properly and some of
them were tough and
it was so emotional and Anderson was
emotional but his drive to be respectful
and to make sure that everybody who'd
lost their life was acknowledged and
done so in a respectful way and the way
he did that in that short chunk of time
um and earnestly showed me who he was
and then when he read their names he
became he's human
he's not a robot and I was taken by that
the thing that is the most important
about Anderson to me and it's something
that is really important that I've
learned here at Yale in my short time
and through my time in the military
we are in a time when it's easy to
dehumanize one another and Anderson
interviews a lot of different people and
is in a lot of different situations and
I've never ever seen him
even though he might disagree I've never
seen him dehumanize another person I
think that's a super important thing
right now and I think it's an example
for all of us and with that I'll shut up
and let him get after it
[Applause]
I realize that my incitement to just get
going with the conversation with you I
didn't properly introduce you Jimmy and
I really apologize so I'm gonna say no
no I'm gonna do it because you know
Anderson won't forgive me I don't so
um what who you just heard from is a
wonderful member for Timothy Dwight
College Community this is James Jimmy
hatch third year student he's part of
the Eli Whitney program he's also the
founder of Spike's canine fund which
advocates for the U.S working canine
population so he's done incredible work
there
and cannot thank you enough for all you
do so okay with that
hello
reading the list of names of people
who've done this before I feel like I've
really brought the gradient down I feel
like you guys were desperate or
something but I appreciate being here
though and thank you all for for coming
um no I did we we were very thoughtful
there were many other people you
shouldn't start off with U.S presidents
that's
a little intimidating I gotta say
oh I don't know especially Truman like
wow okay did he like sit here
okay no no that would be be the wrong
time yeah I know but that's okay
um
so I would say
um I was as we were joking before on our
way here that for me preparing for this
conversation with you was a little bit
like cramming for an exam where I was
madly reading and rereading
um works of yours and I really chat GPT
will take care of it
the TD Community knows a little bit too
much about me and Chachi BT but that's
another story
um but but in all seriousness looking
looking at all the things you have
accomplished and and here you are with
your CNM badge right up here
um along with the publication starting
with dispatches from The Edge and uh
that was back in
2005. I want to say two thousand
probably 2006. yeah there's my first
book I wrote yeah and then Vanderbilt
rise and fall of an American Dynasty
2021 one yes there's a lot in between I
don't quite understand how you have the
time to do all of that while being on
CNN while being on 60 minutes and then
doing all the things that you've done so
I'm curious to hear how you see your
writing projects that you've done along
the way if you don't mind I would
certainly like to start there and and is
has there been a pathway a vision of
what you would so yeah so I've written
um well uh three I'm writing a fourth
book now my first book dispatches from
The Edge was a book I'd been writing in
my head for probably 10 years I wrote it
in 2006
um I got offered the opportunity to
write it during the Hurricane Katrina
coverage
um and which is when I guess some people
started to notice me more a little bit
and so
um actually a kid I went to high school
with who turned out to be a literary
agent actually a kid I went to like
Elementary School with and have known my
entire life who used to be in a heavy
metal band I'd lost touch with him he
called me up he was turns out he's a
literary agent now I'm like how did that
happen
um but uh yeah he became my literary
agent and uh I wrote this book and I
I've been writing this book in my head
for a long time my brother Carter died
by Suicide right before my senior year
at Yale so my senior year was kind of a
blur here I took a year off after
college and I became very interested in
sort of and also my dad died when I was
10 as my mom referenced in Jimmy's
reading so I was always very interested
in sort of survival and how why two
people growing up in a house why does
one person survive and and the other
person does it the same
kind of per you we were the same kind of
people what happened
um and I and that always expanded to
sort of society as I was interested in
societies that Fallen apart
um whether it's through war or political
situations or whatever it may be and and
so as a child I used to read a lot about
I was fascinated by like Zaire uh which
was at that time run by uh president
mabutu
um so I would read a lot about that I
was fascinated like British colonial
wars I was like what the hell was that
all about like these British people
marching along attacking the Zulus and
um so I was fascinated and sort of
places on the planet that I wanted to go
to and I came up with this idea after
college to ultimately I ended up having
a friend make a fake press pass I
borrowed a camera I just started going
to Wars and um but I was very much
driven by this idea of loss and survival
and so even if I didn't really plan on
becoming a reporter I just I wanted to
go places where the language of loss was
spoken and where you know people don't
talk about grief and loss here very much
and I certainly didn't I found it very
hard to talk about but I wanted to
immerse myself in places where people
were suffering and where there where
people did speak about this and I wanted
to understand it and I found when I got
to some places
um I found an odd
uh ability to operate in these
environments and I felt in fact it
easier in some ways not easier but in
some ways
it was comfortable for me to be in some
environments more so than like being
back home so
um so yeah so that book was really a
book about death and loss and survival
and so it was sort of set against the
backdrop of 2005 which had Hurricane
Katrina and the tsunami and all sorts of
stories there was a lot of stories I
covered that year and then all they all
centered around death and loss
um so it's sort of the twin stories of
what happened to my brother and uh and
also all these places I was along the
way
yeah and then I wrote a book with my mom
like I didn't write for again for like
10 years later 10 10 more years or so
because I had nothing to say and um and
then my mom turned 91 and she sent me
this really kind of interesting odd cool
email as she often did and uh it was all
about being how she still felt 17 and
something her grandmother had said to
her when she was 17. anyway I decided
you know we should have a conversation
for a year because like you know when
you're you have a parent often you just
know them as your parent you don't
really know them as a person there's a
friend and so I knew my mom
extraordinarily well
um but there were still all these things
I kind of didn't understand about her
and there's a lot I don't know about my
dad and I thought you know my mom's 91 I
don't want her to die and there would be
anything left unsaid between us and I
don't want there to be any questions so
if we had a conscious conversation for a
year I sound like Gwyneth Paltrow like
conscious uncoupling but we had a uh we
had a conscious conversation for a year
mostly over email
um the because I was traveling and stuff
but uh where she would ask me questions
I would ask her questions and we'd just
go back and forth and it was this
amazing conversation that I didn't
intend to write as a book but about
halfway through I was like you know what
actually I think we could kind of make
this into a book and
um yeah so that's was that that was and
then the Vanderbilt was this book I
wrote two years ago I the first time I
had a co-writer
um a historian Catherine Howe who did
most of the research
um and I didn't really know anything
about the Vanderbilt family I mean my
mom was Gloria Vanderbilt but she was
always thought of herself as like a
changeling she thought she was sort of
an imposter in the in that family and
wasn't really part of that family based
on some crazy stuff that happened to her
as a kid
um and so I grew up not really knowing
anything about them and I consciously
didn't really want to know anything
about them
um you know when I got to Yale everyone
was like oh you're staying in the
Vanderbilt room and I was like hey
that's not really a thing and B uh I
wouldn't even if I could because I
really want nothing to do with them
but then once I had kids I suddenly
realized well what am I going to tell my
kids about this kind of weird thing that
happened in the past that I'm related to
apparently and um so yeah so I started
doing research and decided to write that
book
it feels like there hasn't been that Gap
because in the in the first book the
dispatches book I'm basically
regurgitating the same stuff yeah I'm
just waiting for enough people to die
off they don't realize
oh it's the same book again
[Laughter]
voice and talking about the things in
your life that had been really with you
and sort of but you hadn't really
explored yeah while taking us through
the insane year that was 2005 beginning
with the 2004 tsunami yeah so you're
reading you're going back and forth
between your coverage dealing with so
much deaths and destruction and and
really feeling that incredible
responsibility to every single person
you're meeting to tell the story bear do
more than bear witness I mean you
describe it so powerfully as people are
hoping you're going to make a difference
by with by them talking to you yeah
um while at the same time you're talking
through your own efforts to really talk
about the pain and suffering you've
personally gone through right so then
you go from that to I think the the book
with your the the conscious conversation
with your mother it seems as though and
you never stopped having that
conversation and I guess is what I'm
saying yeah I mean I yeah those are all
things I still think about all the time
I mean you know I I think um for anybody
who lost a parent in this room early on
as a child you know the um uh
uh
anybody you know if you lose a parent
early on it changes the trajectory of
your life and and I certainly wasn't
able to talk about it the death of my
dad was so overwhelming was so stunning
to me
um and even now you know it's it's my
voice shakes a little bit when I think
about it and so
um I like talking about it now but it
that was something I just didn't speak
of and so going to places where people
did speak about loss because they were
in the midst of a loss they had just
experienced the loss of a child or loss
for their family or you know an entire
Village wiped out or whatever it was
um I couldn't help but
I mean you know I probably could have
just gone to therapy and that would have
probably made a little more sense early
on uh but uh you know
it was it was an extraordinary I mean I
I both as something that I cared very
much about bearing witness to what is
happening in the world and and bearing
witness to the suffering of others and
the pain that others feel
um and and also you know I mean I
couldn't help but feel a commonality in
some sense
yeah it it seemed as one is working our
way through that book you know we land
in New Orleans in terms of her Hurricane
Katrina you're you're telling us again
and again how how shocking the whole
experience was for you in terms of it
being here in the United States
um so I'm curious prior to that was most
of your career out in the world yeah
most most everything I did was overseas
I really I was I felt like there's a lot
of reporters in America and like I what
am I I'm like a guy with a fake press
pass and a camera why am I going to try
to compete with somebody at the White
House reporting so yeah my first story I
snuck into Myanmar uh Burma I hooked up
with some students fighting the Burmese
government and I shot a story about them
um I then ended up enrolling in school
and uh in Hanoi in the last six months
of the U.S embargo because I wanted to
be some place where there weren't many
Americans because I thought that'd be an
interesting experience
um so there were very small number of
Americans in Hanoi at the time uh like I
think maybe 20 or so
um and yeah so I studied Vietnamese for
a while and I shot five stories and then
I still didn't get a job
um and but I was airing these things on
a thing called channel one which was a
show scene in about half the high
schools and middle schools in America in
the early 90s
um if you know you know and if you don't
like you think it's ridiculous but uh it
it had this huge audio audience of kids
and teachers nobody knew about it but
they I was a fact Checker there for like
six months then that's when I came up
with the idea of the just going to Wars
and that's what I did and so they would
like air the stuff but they still didn't
hire me and then I I I'd left high
school early and I'd ridden in a truck
across sub-Saharan Africa for six months
so I was still sort of familiar with
Eastern Africa and so I pitched okay I'm
gonna go to
10 countries over the next three months
and I'm going to shoot 10 stories and
these are the stories I think I'm going
to be able to shoot and um the first one
was Somalia in the early days of a
famine in August of 92 before the US got
involved before Black Hawk Down if
you've seen that movie it was about a
year before that or eight months before
that
um and uh yeah and Somalia was it had a
big impact on the channel one audience a
lot of people started raising money for
it and stuff and they then they hired me
full-time as like their warperson
foreign correspondent so yeah Bosnia in
the Civil War Sarajevo briefly in Rwanda
during the genocide South Africa a lot
for the uh run up to the years before
and the election of Mandela
um Soviet Georgia wherever there was
fighting I mean I would sort of go
Colombia Haiti for when the U.S invaded
after Raul sedros and I was very
interested in conflict and and I wanted
to see it I wanted to experience and
document what people were going through
yeah for you
he meanting something like an
environmental disaster like a hurricane
or a tsunami versus War
um I mean logistically there are some
differences and in terms of you know
obviously Safety and Security there
there are differences
um you know not that which by the way
when I started nobody cared about my
safety or security other than me uh so
like it wasn't like there was I didn't
have like a News Network behind me so I
was just out there by myself doing
really stupid stuff so I'm not
encouraging other people to do that
um because there was a kid named Dan
Eldon who was doing the exact same thing
I was and he was hacked to death by a
mob um in in Somalia
um and others uh but
uh but but no I think
uh I mean obviously there everything is
different I try not to compare one thing
to another because I don't think there
should be like a a sliding scale of
sorrow and and I think you should you
need to see everything with fresh eyes
you need to see everything as if it's
the first time you're seeing it because
if if you're so jaded at a certain point
it's very easy to like start to compare
one thing to another like oh it's not as
bad as this place was you know 10 years
ago and if you start to do that you're
not seeing it as you should see it and
and that's a real risk that can happen
um I found myself in Rwanda in uh you
know right after the elections with
Mandela I went to Rwanda and this
country I'd been in a number of times as
a teenager
um in happier times and uh I was with
the RPF the Rondo and patriotic front
and went to some Villages where people
have been uh slaughtered and I took a
photograph and by this point I've been
doing this for about three years and I
took a photograph with my own personal
camera of five people who were laying on
the side of the road who had been who
had decomposed on the side of a road and
um I was very interested in that moment
in how the skin on this person's hand
had peeled off like a glove and I took a
photograph of it and there was another
reporter a journal a photojournalist who
I'd linked up with who were sort of
traveling because I had access to a
vehicle and he hitched a ride with us he
took a photograph of me doing that and
he sent it to me later and he said this
is for when you become famous
um and he
said something else to me and what he
was saying to me was
your
you've like you're gone too far and I
actually have that picture up in my on
my bulletin board at work because it was
it was a real for me it was a
realization that I was no longer seeing
those five people I believe they were
family I was no longer seeing them as a
daughter and a mother and a father and
probably a son I was interested in how
the skin was peeling off somebody's hand
and and
so I stopped for for quite a while doing
that sort of work because I didn't want
to forget like I wanted I didn't want to
see it like that I wanted to see it and
be horrified by it and not you know
interested in the sort of the things
that happen
um so yeah I think that's an important
thing to keep in mind for me that's a
really important thing to not you know
you run across reporters sometimes who
are very sort of jaded and they've been
around the world and they've been doing
it for years and it you know you're not
doing Justice to the people you're there
to report on if you can't
if you're not horrified by things and if
you're not stunned by things and
um at least for me I think I I can't do
that
yeah and you talk a lot about
forcing us to see the things that we
might not want to see but yet at the
same time I think as as Jimmy so
eloquently said never dehumanizing so
it's not not easy to do and I really
applaud you for doing that and I'm just
curious how how do you manage to feel
like you never lose sight of that line
[Music]
um
I I don't know I mean I I hope I don't I
mean I try to be very conscious of it I
you know I'm very interested in
you know I'm sort of awkward around
human beings I'm like very shy and
introverted but when I'm working I'm
very
uh engaged with somebody and it's sort
of the only time I can really engage and
really focus on somebody and not the
only time you know that's not that weird
but
um
um but I do think it it's uh uh yeah I
don't know I don't really know how to
answer that question I mean I I think
it's important to not lose sight of the
fact that that human these are all human
beings involved in things you know when
we're covering politicians who are
saying awful stupid ridiculous things uh
it's interesting you know it's it's easy
to not think of somebody as a human
being it's easy to just think of them as
you know in Rwanda during you know in
the run-up to the genocide on the
Rwandan radio they would call Tootsie's
cockroaches and the whole idea is to
dehumanize people so that you can then
take the next step and do things to them
so I you know even people you don't like
I think it's important to view them as
flawed human beings and try to see walk
in their shoes and see where they're
coming from and understand why they're
making the arguments they're making what
forces are at play in their world in
their in their work life
um but you know just on on just
day-to-day coverage of things you know
if there's a you know there's a there
was an active shooter today in uh
Louisville
um you know I have a policy I don't show
active Shooters I don't name them
history has recorded these people's
names and I don't think anybody in this
room could name somebody who died at
Columbine maybe somebody could but
um the you know you could probably name
The Killers of Columbine much more than
you can name any of the people who were
killed and I think that goes for for
many of the active shooting situations
so
um yeah I just
I have a policy I I don't show their
pictures I I report on them I report on
motivations I report on whatever needs
to be reported on but I don't I try to
always focus on naming the people who
have been killed naming those whose
lives were lost and that's just I mean
it's a small thing in the grand scale of
things but it does sort of
uh it is a guidepost for the way I view
a lot of a lot of things I report on
there's there's no lack of news in the
world and and today's shooting is only
one of many things that keep happening
it must be really difficult to be able
to make the decision of what gets aired
what what gets
put on in in the time that you have yeah
I mean you know there's a certain
um because I I'm not
motivated by ideology and coverage so
there's a in some ways it's not that
difficult because things which are
happening you know my my focus is what
has happened today or what is
you know um
what's in the news today or what's
what's an important story
um and some of it is you know tempered
by where where do we have correspondence
where are people where you know what
stories do we have ready to go uh what
guests can we get so some of the
coverage is based on that but you know
for me it's it's not
um for me it's based on
what's happened today usually often
takes precedence but if it's obviously
an ongoing story it's what the latest
thing on that is rather than you know if
you're ideologically motivated and you
you have a channel which is geared
toward
um you know spreading election lies then
your coverage can be based on it doesn't
need to be based on anything that's
happened on that particular day it can
be just driving toward that and that
doesn't interest me have you ever had to
really push for air time of something
yeah certainly look it's always a
discussion I have an executive producer
who I've worked with for 20 something
years at CNN he and I've been together
in a lot of really dangerous places and
um he's you know uh puts up with me and
so we're I'm lucky to work with him and
so we know each other very well but he
and I have I mean it's an ongoing
discussion all day long you know we have
a conference call in the morning all
throughout the day we're figuring out
okay
you know everything we think we're going
to do in the morning that we think will
be on the evening she'll have a show
that's on from eight to nine
um a lot of you know 70 of that might
might not make it on by the the time and
the show we have ready to go at 7 59 you
know in 59 seconds you know the second
before we go on air that can all be
tossed out the moment we go on and
something else happens so the story in
Tennessee on the lawmakers the you know
three lawmakers who were voted uh two of
them were only expelled
um
you know that started breaking just 20
minutes or so before the the eight
o'clock show began and you know that was
not what we had planned to do most of
the show on but we ended up I think
doing the first 30 minutes just live we
had cameras in the hallway we had
interviews with one of the lawmakers
just after he was voted out we were
following the vote as it was going on we
were able to pull in you know
interesting guests on it so it's a
combination of factors that kind of go
into it so you're taking the day off
today I am yes I yes it's a rare time
that I take the day off yeah
um yeah they don't yes it's sort of like
in the Charlie Brown you know like when
you know in the Charlie Brown spelling
bee when you spell a word wrong it's
like and then they just go like you just
disappear so uh nobody you know I feel
like if I disappear too long from the
screen that someone else will just
replace me who's much smarter and better
so
so you won't have to disappear at eight
o'clock to go do your show we'll see
we'll see what happens let me see what
time it is now oh we got plenty of time
so
um yeah I could like honestly worst case
scenario it's 442
um like if I needed to I could do a show
from here probably at eight if I had to
you could do it from dinner we could oh
yeah I'd probably have to go off to a
side thing but uh yeah we we've done
we've done we've done shows in some
weird areas okay we looked that in mind
okay um
what's the biggest change for you as an
anchor versus being out there traveling
the world and you know the the nice I
mean it's such a ridiculous term anchor
I you know um I uh
I the
you know I I started out as I said just
overseas
um and so with the first certainly three
years I was just you know this person
with a small camera it started getting
like one producer or two producers from
channel one and we would all travel
together and we'd all shoot
um but it didn't seem to be going
anywhere it wasn't like I didn't think I
wasn't planning like this is my Pathway
to finally getting that that anchor job
I've always dreamed of to me the vision
of an anchor was like Kent Brockman on
The Simpsons so that I wasn't really
aiming for that
um and he is sort of an accurate
representation of some folks but um
uh the the
you know then literally I did
Newsweek uh there used to be a magazine
called Newsweek um that did an article
about channel one and they showed they
they wrote about some of the stuff I had
done because it was like this weird kid
who shows up in these places and he
shoots these stories and um
and ABC uh read that and asked for tape
and I thought they were kidding I
thought it was like a joke that somebody
was calling and um anyway I learned it
was and I put together tape and so they
hired me as a correspondent which was
insane because I was 27 and in those
days they didn't hire anybody in that
age
um but uh but I never really wanted to
like anchoring just seemed uh not like
something I was pretty interested in but
I started anchoring on the evening on a
overnight newscast
um but the nice thing about CNN is you
still they still want you out in the
field they still want you going to you
know anchoring just gives you a little
bit more the ability to frankly choose
where you go so my day is much more
determined by myself than it would be if
I you know if I was a correspondent
waking up every day I might get sent
someplace and I knew one day I wanted to
have kids and I wanted to be able to at
least have some agency over my schedule
but but it's nice because you can you
know your question earlier about can you
argue about where you know I can insist
on going I did a whole week in in DRC
Congo which used to be Zaire which I was
obsessed with as a kid and I'm still
fascinated by DRC Congo so I go there a
lot and I did a whole week of shows from
there which you know is not necessarily
where
a news network is probably going to want
to send you for a week because it's very
expensive and difficult to work there
um but you know they knew it was an
important story that I was wanting to do
and I was doing something a story about
sexual violence on Eastern Congo and um
you know they supported me in it so that
you're able to to get stuff on the air
that you might otherwise not if you have
maybe if you're an anchor because you
you have your own show you can kind of
determine that
so I think I'm starting to see a little
bit of how you're able to write books
because you're able to control your time
a little bit more yeah I I also I mean
until I've had kids I've had no life so
like I don't know like you may think
like I've had some like glamorous fun
like I this is all I've been doing like
I haven't been out there
like enjoying myself like in you know my
entire 20s all my friends were like
having dinners and going out to clubs
and stuff and I was I lost all my
friends because I was always away and
they like I'd constantly cancel any you
know meet up or dinner or whatever I had
with because if something would happen
and I would just be off and so after a
while people were like oh why even
called this guy so it made it much
easier for me I'm that friend so it made
it much easier to just focus on work and
so I've really you know and I've loved
it because the work has been the most
exciting thing I could possibly imagine
it everything else pales in comparison I
mean there's nothing more extraordinary
in my mind than you know something
happens in the world and I can get on I
can get on a plane and I can actually go
to wherever I can go to Ukraine and in
within a 24-hour period or you know
however long it takes to get there you
know I can be in a tank moving toward a
front line with with Ukrainian soldiers
or I can be and that's an extraordinary
thing to be able to to drop in to other
people's lives and in the most and it's
not just visiting other people's lives
it's dropping in people's lives and the
most intense
sometimes horrific but or exciting or
whatever it is most important moment of
their life often or often where their
life is is you know under a threat and
to be able to tell their story and
allowed to tell their Story by them and
to kind of
you know be able to to try to do justice
to the sights and the sounds and the
smells of it and and and bring that you
know and send that and and package that
and and write it in a way that that is
accurate to me there's just why wouldn't
I do that all the time it's it's
incredible I cannot believe I get to do
it
so you describe that in in and written a
book that that have a history a history
work yeah Vanderbilt which
the research processes can't can't be as
as exciting and glamorous as what you
just described I assume it's a lot of
pouring over well it's more my world
well as I said this is the first book I
had I co-wrote so uh Catherine Howe who
is a great historian and writer she did
most of the the legwork on it so I
cannot claim to to have you know
um I benefited from the arduous hours
that she put in
um but you know I certainly read
extensively history books and uh but for
me what was interesting about trying to
write a history book and and
particularly on the Vanderbilts is you
know look there have been people
surprise written books people are
surprised winning books about Commodore
Vanderbilt who was my great great or
great I three or four grades a
grandfather who was you know not not a
nice person I mean he was you know
probably he had he had a self-described
Mania for money he very well could have
been a psychopath
um there's a lot more Psychopaths out
there than I think we all realize
um in the world of business and and
maybe media as well
um but uh but I wanted to to me what was
interesting is not to try to write a
linear history because there's no way I
would write something as as good as has
already been written out there but was
to to kind of drop in in the in moments
in these historical figures lives
um and and kind of see them as as humans
and see them
sort of how the money the the Ripple
effects of you know that you have a this
patriarch of a family who is obsessed
with money and as a Mania for money and
from the age of 11 and bills you know by
the year Commodore Vanderbilt died in
1877 uh one out of every 15 or whatever
twenty dollars in circulation belonged
to him
so you know he died with 100 million
dollars which today is not you know
people you think well bezos's boat cost
500 million
um but 100 million dollars back then I
mean it was an extraordinary figure
um he had more money than the U.S
treasury had and his son doubled that
fortune in eight years which is
incredible and what's even more
incredible is that the third and fourth
generation went on a spending spree the
likes which you cannot believe and
unlike the Asters who I'm writing a book
about now they didn't reinvest it in
like the land that became New York they
built these enormous palaces
um and gave Vanderbilt Hall
um
they built these enormous palaces you
know that were torn down within 60 years
because they were so bloated and needed
you know a servants 60 servants to run
them and tax laws change and inheritance
taxes change and no one wanted to live
in these houses and uh and they were
sold off for scrap and to me that's
fascinating The Arc of that
um you know it's always interesting
because you know my I come from this
family and and
from my entire life everybody assumed
that I was like the Scion of the
Vanderbilt family and would be
inheriting great wealth from the
Vanderbilts like as if there was some
sort of giant Vanderbilt slush fund that
that I was about to be immersed in at
the age of 21.
um and both my parents like you know my
dad took me to see The Commodore
Vanderbilt statue which is outside Grand
Central Station in New York as he
founded Grand Central Station
um and uh he owned the 16 Acres of
Midtown Manhattan at the time don't know
what happened to that
um but my dad took me my dad to grew a
very poor in Mississippi and a farm took
me to see the statue when I was like I
don't know 12 or something or maybe 10
and to explain to me that this is like
my great great great grandfather and I
the only thing I came away understanding
is that all grandparents turned into
statues when they died so I must have
been it must have been like six actually
at the time
um but what he was showing me was to
then to let me know that As I Grew Older
I would hear more about this family that
my mom had belonged to but that you know
to not buy into it to not believe that
there was something like pot of gold
waiting for me because there wasn't
there was no trust fund there was no
nothing like that and I'm very lucky
that that was the case because you look
at the history of the Vanderbilts all of
whom inherited great fortunes
um they didn't a lot of them didn't do
much with their lives they spent a lot
of money in fact one of them said that
inheriting money is like equals like
it's like um I forgot his quote but it's
like it's as bad as cocaine because like
it just you think it's gonna last
forever and it feels great and uh you do
nothing and that's really
um to me sort of why I wanted to write
these books for my kids because I don't
want them to feel like that there's some
pot of gold waiting for them because
there's not
just a giant cautionary taste it's a
giant cautionary tale yes I think all
I'm fascinated by this whole like all
these people who we all look to you know
people on the not the people you know
you look people on the cover of People
magazine and all these people we read
about and look at on social media and we
think wow it's incredible I view them as
like deeply warped and in need of
serious help like I mean I'm fascinated
that we all are like brought up to look
at these people and think like oh my God
if only and like when you actually look
at their lives the misery of commodore
Vanderbilt he sent his wife to an insane
asylum so he could shoot up the
babysitter
thank you
it's true
so I was gonna say with so many people
that you could have chosen to I mean
obviously yeah your your your statue
ancestor has to be in the story because
he's distorted yes but but once you get
past him there's so many people you
could have lingered on so I'm curious if
there were people that you you if you
had more chapters who would you have
added back into the book
um
you know I I actually I'm pretty you're
good yeah I'm good like after I like I
enjoyed spending time with them at a
certain point like I didn't want to
spend any more time with them like I'm
writing this book about the Asters now
and um uh and there's a lot of dreadful
lasters I mean they're just sort of
dreadful after a while you just don't
want to spend any more time with them
um they they make the Vanderbilt seem I
don't know more fun and
[Laughter]
well you describe the few that went on
between
Caroline Astor and um Alva Vanderbilt
yes yeah I mean so basically I mean it's
I don't know it's uh it puts the like
the Jersey Shore Housewives show yeah
whatever yeah yeah yeah there was this
epic view there's this one it's too long
involved to go into I can't even yeah
yeah we'll have to talk about it okay
off camera okay
um so much there but no I'm I'm really I
can tell you're a historian because this
I know I was just like loving every
single moment you'd have such a
beautiful way of um you and Catherine
how have such a beautiful way of
rendering the past and some so much of
this history I'm very familiar with but
I really enjoy I felt like I was there
at these crazy balls yeah that it's nice
because there was a lot of first-person
accounts on on on with the Vanderbilts
but the Astro is actually not so much so
it's actually it's It's Tricky but um
but yeah the Astros actually destroyed
their records pretty much every
generation which isn't interesting
um uh
yeah so yep and then poor Consuelo being
locked into her room for her wedding
yeah all those things right you guys
consueloven was like married off to uh
the Vanderbilts they had money but they
had no they didn't have entree to New
York Society so back then that was you
know they had so much money that that
seemed important to them uh to like get
into New York society and one of the
ways was to start marrying off people to
uh to British nobility so they would get
a British title and all the British
nobility were all like counts of no
account as my grandmother used to say
meaning they they had the title but they
had no money
um so it was this perfect match of like
Nouveau riche well you know ridiculously
wealthy tacky uh New Yorkers marrying
you know the Duke of Marlborough and you
know they get married in misery ensues
for Generations
it's true they're all miserable yeah
yeah they don't they do not look happy
no they're miserable yeah
um well
so so
the Astro book gonna come out
um I think September oh wow so you're
almost there yeah yeah uh yes I'm doing
uh edits right now okay yeah
we'll make that okay sure
um but you have another project that's
going and that's been really uh
different the podcast yes that's what
the world needs another podcast yeah
yeah
maybe not but but your podcast is really
my podcast is special that is true thank
you for saying that yeah
uh yeah so yeah uh I I I
um I had no interest in doing a podcast
I did not think the world needs another
podcast and yet here I am I did I yeah I
I did a eight season uh eight episode
podcast about grief and loss and um uh I
found my mom died three years ago and
yeah 2019
um and uh it was four years ago and
while going through her stuff which is
this process everybody who has lost
somebody goes through
um I found it incredibly lonely and
isolating and in going through her stuff
my mom was like a very fancy hoarder uh
there was a lot of stuff and it was also
my father's stuff and my brother's stuff
because all of that had just been packed
away and nobody had ever gone through it
so I'm the last surviving member of the
little family that I was born into
um and so I was you know going through a
story storage room full of boxes
and it was like the storage room in I
don't know if you remember the closing
scene of Raiders of the Lost Ark where
there's like all just the ark is stored
in this Warehouse of boxes
um and I like that nobody below the age
of 25 is not in their head because they
haven't seen them
um but uh
um so I just found it incredibly
isolating and I started I'm a big I like
this book Victor Frankel's Man's Search
for meaning and and one of the things
Victor Frankl writes about is he's a
psychologist who was in Auschwitz he exp
he talks about narrating experiences in
his horrible experiences in his head as
a way of going through them and so he he
narrates them as he would sort of a
professor narrating a clinical uh
situation and I found myself uh
narrating as I'm going through all these
boxes as I would or corresponded if I
was like writing the story I was sort of
narrating in my head this stuff and I
just started recording it and
um ended up putting this together with
some interviews with some people who
discussed loss and grief in ways that
blew my mind and one of them was Stephen
Colbert whose father and two uh younger
brothers were killed in an Eastern
Airlines plane crash when Stephen was 10
years old
and Stephen talks about grief in a way
that I I've never heard before and um
and I'd done a brief interview with him
years ago about it and so he's in the
podcast and and it's all these people
it's Lori Anderson who's a really cool
musician
um Elizabeth Alexander who was here at
Yale
um so it's just different ways of
thinking about grief and loss and it's
yeah it's I've been surprised at the
response to it has been pretty
extraordinary
especially in this moment in time when
we're coming out of covid we're I mean
obviously as you said death is something
that we all go through having to survive
it deal with the aftermath but I think
we're in a place maybe in American
society in the world that is dealing
that has been dealing with so much death
and maybe your podcast is coming along
at a time that we all need it to really
find our way through it yeah I mean yeah
I don't know about that but I think so I
wouldn't say we all need it I mean it's
just a little podcast but but but but no
but it's been what's nice is that uh I
mean for me
uh you know it has made me feel less
alone in this in this kind of bizarre
world of grief to to realize that I'm on
this road that you know everybody will
be on at some point
um and and generations of people have
been here before you know we all you
know I remember you know at Yale and
it's a perfect example you know
anybody's an undergraduate here you all
live in rooms of dead people you all
live in the rooms of generations of
people who have been in those rooms
before and you all we all think you know
Robert Heinlein said you know every
generation thinks they invented sex and
every generation is wrong you know we
all think we're the first to like have
these experiences that we're having and
to be facing the issues we're facing and
as one ages you start to realize like
they're I mean and it's an obvious thing
but there are you know
everybody there's not anything you are
going through in your life that has not
already been gone through by generations
of people before you and I take great
comfort in that I like it literally
helps me when I'm in a situation where I
feel completely overwhelmed and I you
know or like my career is about to be
ruined or my life is about to be
distorted or whatever it is and realize
like somebody has been in this situation
before and there's a way out of it and
things will take their course and uh and
grief is the same way you know there's
not any permutation of my grief that is
original or different and yet it feels
that way to me and I feel completely
alone in it but realizing that realizing
you know all these people who have been
here before is going through the same
things I follow on Instagram to cycle
the AIDS Memorial and to me it's the the
most incredible thing on Instagram
um uh and it's it's just
photographs of people have died
put up by their loved ones with little
stories about them and I see myself on
the in that page you know every couple
of days I'm like that that's like that's
me or that's my friend you know Joe or
whatever it is and
um it's just these generations of people
who are no longer here but who went
through the exact same stuff and I find
great comfort in that maybe I'm just
weird but no no
um I will say that for people who are
are not quite prepared to to be part of
that conversation it is quite an
emotional experience I will say like I I
clicked on it just to see what you were
doing and no no it'll like stop you dead
in your tracks and like make your weak
yeah yeah no what I but I like there's
nothing wrong with that like for me for
me I think it's so needed yeah
we're just have to keep going
Yeah but I
but we should make time it's very
important
yeah Greece is not something too yeah
look I I think look I I wasn't able to
talk about loss for my entire life and I
you know my brother died right before uh
senior year and I mean I was stunned and
completely
you know senior year I was like I I
don't know what I'm doing I I didn't
apply for any jobs I didn't you know I
like I graduated I had no idea what was
was going to happen what I was going to
do and and um
you know I it uh so yeah I think
yeah I I don't know I I certainly would
have benefited from uh
you know I wish I had been able to talk
about it's not that I didn't know I
should I certainly knew I should and you
know
um but yeah I didn't
so maybe this is not the best place to
end but I do realize that we're really
bringing it down here no I
I pick up we are in the Porsche
portion sure yeah we
[Music]
we get to our q a and we did have five
students who had submitted questions
that we are
um
I think we have time for so if the five
students could sort of stand up and
raise their hands so that our
um
excellent you're all very close together
kind of Mega is all the way out there
this is really like the honor System I
thought like 20 other people would be
like oh yeah I'm one of the
okay
this is this is what happens when you're
in a college where the head of college
knows who everybody is trying to to fake
it out
um but yes we can we can go in this
direction Megan you want to be first go
for it
hi thank you so much for being here with
us today hey um this feels like really
unreal to just be able to talk to you me
too
um my name is Mika Joshi I'm a senior in
Timothy Dwight college and I was
wondering how do you feel that large
News Network such as CNN affect the
polarization of America and what do you
do in your profession specifically to
try and minimize it yeah look I think
um we live in incredibly polarized
Society I think it's been polarized for
a very long time
um certainly any reading of History
shows that and our media has also uh you
know if you look at you know Alexander
Hamilton started the New York Post uh in
order to get his point across
um
I think
I think it's difficult
um I think it's something it's certainly
something I think about all the time
it's something I worry about all the
time
um and I know everybody in my Orbit who
I work with it's of great concern as
well
um
you know
I try not to I'm not interested in being
a liberal newscast or a conservative
newscast I don't watch
partisan newscast like that I'm not
interested in what some
overpaid anchor thinks about
you know what candidate they support or
what what policy they like I don't I
don't want to like I'm not interested in
that I I think your viewers
you know should make up their own minds
about stuff I believe in facts and I
believe in presenting people with facts
and talking to people
from different walks of life and
different political positions and
letting viewers make up their mind
um I you know I do think in an age where
when people lie
um I think it's the Java journalists to
to point that out that they are lying
that can also at times
you can that can you know many people
think they are doing that and that can
be very partisan in some ways if you
believe
if you are seeing things through a
certain ideological prism and you are
confronting People based on your prism
and you think you're doing it because
it's true and what they're saying is
false then that can be partisan so I
think these are all things you have to
be constantly conscious of and
constantly
um concerned about bias and bias in many
different forms not just political bias
but you know economic you know the lens
through which we see everybody sees
things through a lens and that lens is
influenced by the geography of where
you're from the background you have the
political beliefs you have whatever it
is there are many kinds of of biases and
I think it's important to be aware of
all all of them I don't
um
you know I do think we are living in an
age where there's so much information
and you know when I was growing up it
was three broadcast news channels and uh
it was you know ABC CBS and NBC and
Walter Cronkite and I don't know who
else was on the other ones everyone
watched Walter Cronkite or Roger mud I
guess for a while was on NBC
um
and you know people now a lot of people
from my generation and older look back
at that and think oh that was the Golden
Age of news like we trusted those people
those people were good we trusted them
but if you actually look back like the
original newscasts were 18 minutes long
and so that's what people they people
thought they were getting in 18 minutes
they thought they were getting
everything they needed to know that
that's the way that's the way it was was
Walter cronkite's tagline
um and I had great respect for him I
think he was an amazing person but you
know the newsrooms were all white they
were all male uh all generally New York
Washington
um there's weren't a lot of weren't
people of color you know gay people I
mean they were very it was a very uh you
know small lens that you were seeing
things through and I think it's easy to
look for people of a certain generation
to look back on that and think oh that
was a time of where you know where you
could really trust what you were seeing
um I actually think you know we're
living this extraordinary time of
information where we all you know have
in this room on our on our phones access
to to
more information than anybody in the you
know history of the world has ever had
access to
um and I think that's an amazing thing I
think it's also a uh it's overwhelming I
think it contributes to this feeling of
that the world is just getting worse and
worse and like things are so out of
control I actually think that the
opposite is true I think the world is is
better than it's ever been before and I
think if you look at the data by just
about every metric your life is way
better than anybody's ever lived on the
planet and your future I mean obviously
there's tremendous you know
climate change all sorts of things to be
concerned about but you know literacy
rates life expectancy
I mean by just about every metric life
is better than it's ever been and is
only getting better so
um it's a long way of entering I think
it's a real issue I I you know I try not
to contribute to polarization I try not
to
demonize people as Jimmy was saying I
try not to fall into the sort of left
right thing I I try to you know talk to
people from different backgrounds and
understand where they're coming from and
present that to viewers that's what I
believe in
thank you okay who come back pop back up
who was
uh I guess Caitlyn you're next
hello my name is Caitlin I'm a sophomore
in TD cool um and I was curious so
you've covered a lifetime of stories but
is there one story you feel that you
covered that didn't receive the
attention or the emotional reaction that
it merited
um and if so how did this experience
change your perspective on our media
consumption hmm
[Music]
yeah look I I
yeah a lot of the stuff I'm interested
in people aren't interested in so
um I get that and that's okay
um you know people have a lot going on
in their lives and so I I don't I don't
wanna I I will give you a specific
example but I don't want to sound like
I'm pontificating like oh if only people
will listen to me talk about this
everything will be fine
um people are busy they have lives going
on I totally get that and uh you know
everybody has a right to think about
what they feel is important and and find
that information out and I'm glad we
live in an age where we can find out
whatever information you want to find
out you can find out
um you know the things that interest me
I'm drawn to places that a lot of people
don't pay attention to I'm drawn to you
know Democratic Republic of Congo I will
you know I will come back to I I am
fascinated by that country I'm
fascinated
um you know uh
I there's a tremendous uh yeah I mean
violence in eastern Democratic Republic
of Congo is something I'm very
interested in and
um some of the most extraordinary people
I've ever talked to or have been you
know I talked to a woman named Angela
who uh
um
was uh uh she was brutally assaulted in
her Village uh by government forces who
came into the village uh she was
sexually assaulted by a number of people
uh they tried to get her brother
involved in it he resisted so they
slipped his throat in front of her they
threw one of her children on a fire
um then after they left her husband came
back and kicked her out of the village
because he was afraid she was HIV
positive and so when I met her she was
living in another village with her
children her childhood was thrown the
fire survived
and she was waking up every day and
trying to find work and she was living
and surviving and so
um that's somebody like I think about
all the time and the you know uh yeah I
wish
I wish I could have done more for that
person in her life to change her life
and also to tell her story in a way that
more people would see and watch
um but
in all honesty you know she didn't speak
English and that's difficult for some
viewers and it's a tough story and it's
easy to turn the channel on and I
totally understand that and I get that
but for me I think that's when I it's
weird to even bring those things up but
when you're trying to tell somebody's
stories these are all things you have to
think about in terms of how you present
the story and what is the best way to
get that person's story to an audience
and and hopefully people see it and want
to help the organization who is helping
her which is how I found her and so
um
yeah I think that's there there's
there's so many stories we don't pay
attention to that I wish you know
there's a lot of organizations that I
work with after doing stories on them
because I think they're doing great work
and I want to continue that work
um so yeah I don't know if that answers
your question but
hi Anderson thank you so
thank you so much for being here with us
today my name is Arlene and I'm a
sophomore and TD and my question is as a
television journalist what has been the
biggest challenge you have faced on CNN
and how did you navigate it in order to
in order to continue reporting to all
the people watching you hmm
um what's been the biggest challenge
um
hmm I mean there's there's a lot uh you
know
um
uh
uh you know there's there's personal
like you know uh handling stress things
like that uh but I guess more look I
think certainly on in the last
Administration
um it was a challenging environment
um and you know continues to be but but
certainly last Administration was a
challenging environment
um for to be targeted by President
United States to have our the company I
work for targeted by the president
United States
um and to you know it's been an
interesting thing to see the kind of
techniques now being used by people uh
in public life
um and political life to not answer
questions or to just only speak to
outlets that they feel represent their
ideological slant
um and I think as reporters it's been
you know
I've I've worked overseas in in regimes
where you know uh where where truth is
uh is you know uh is not something that
you get is is uh how can I say this
um you know where which are not truthful
and it's difficult you know to figure
out how to work in those environments to
how how to respond in a way that doesn't
it's easy to overreact and it's easier
to kind of
um
yeah I'll just say it was just a
difficult time I I to me personally that
was the hardest thing to not you know
because I don't want to express personal
opinions I'm not interested in
being somebody who wears their opinion
on their sleeve and and tries to force
it on viewers uh I do believe in
listening to other people and and you
know
being prepared for interviews so that
you can factually push back on somebody
but I don't argue with people over their
politics good people can see things in
different ways
um and and there can be some truth on
both sides but I do there are facts and
I try to stick to if I'm in a
contentious
um interview with somebody I try to
stick to facts and what is factually
correct and what they've what they've
said that is not factually correct
um and to me that's the the ground I
like to try to confront somebody on
um hello Mr Cooper um Carla if you kind
of just answered a bit of my question
but
um I just wanted to ask like how do you
separate your own feelings and opinions
from all the things that you cover
um and I know you just said you don't
like to share your opinion but do you
think there's like value in putting your
opinion out there and being honest with
the public of what you think right
um
so uh
I don't I look we live in an age where
everybody is expressing their opinion
and I I think that's great I think it's
great that I I do think that there's a
role
um
you know
I don't think I'm best at
like I I don't yeah I don't believe in
getting up every night and expressing my
opinion on issues which affect people's
lives that I may not understand how
somebody with lived experience sees
something or has experienced something
and so I'm you know I'm not egotistical
enough to believe that I'm egotistical
but I'm not I'm not egotistical enough
to be on TV but not enough to believe
that I know everything or that I'm right
and so I very much view myself as
learning just as our viewers are
learning and I'm generally asking
questions I'm actually interested in
hearing the answers to I'm not
interviewing people who I know reflect a
certain you know Echo chamber that
they're going to give me a political
answer that is going to please me so
that my viewers will only be exposed to
some you know pleasing uh point of view
um you know I believe uh I believe in
being honest in all things I do but it
doesn't necessarily mean that I have to
you know announce ahead of time
you know everything I believe in
um I think you can
if you're if you're if you're focused on
facts if you're focused in a world of of
what is true and what is not true as
opposed to Shades of Gray and an opinion
um for me that's where I I frankly I
think there's a not a lot not enough
people doing that and so I that is where
I choose to focus on
um and
yeah I don't know if that answers your
question but
hi Anderson thank you uh I'm Quinn I'm a
freshman in TD in the past five years
there's been a pretty sharp increase in
the amount of misinformation and false
news that's circulated on the internet
and other sources
and this has led to a pretty large
social shift in terms of how American uh
the American public views news
organizations uh with a large portion of
the population uh solely viewing those
Outlets that align with their opinions
and decrying others as fake news
and
um with this in mind
how can news organizations and
journalists individually work to combat
this problem and reinstall trust in the
news
um look I think
I'll speak for myself I I think it's
important to to
do the best you can and to not be a jerk
and to not uh
get things wrong and to not give in to
your biases and to not you know to think
about all these things and to spend a
lot of time worrying about it and
thinking about it and
um you know I know I do and I know the
people around me do I can't speak you
know I don't know about some of these
other folks and other you know channels
and stuff
um you know I I'm it's fascinating to
see the Dominion lawsuit that's going
forward I don't know how closely you've
been following this but to see sort of
the text exchanges between other anchors
and another Network you know concerned
about the stock price of the parent
company
I I don't know what my parent company
I'm not even sure who my parent company
is these days but like I don't know what
the stock price is it wouldn't even it
would never even occur to me to
like why would I care
um and I you know I'm sure my corporate
overlords whoever they are would
probably not like that but but that's
just not my job and so that that was
sort of I'm not I'm not going to say
surprise me because I know the people
involved and and I you know that doesn't
surprise me but
um
but I think it's you know I think it's
important that that you have personal
standards and personal things that you
personally you know what is right and
what is wrong and what your job is you
know I know what my job is my job is not
to pontificate every night about you
know what I think and that's not why I'm
there I'm there because I've spent a
lifetime of telling other people's
stories and going to places and seeing
things and wanting to bring viewers to
those places so that they can walk in
somebody else's shoes and so that that's
what the only thing I add to this
conversation to add to the table there's
a lot there's a lot of people who do
that other stuff really really well if
you want like really smart liberal
people doing that and if you want really
smart conservative people doing that
they're out there and they have networks
that are doing really well
um
it's just not what I'm just not that way
personally and it's not just doesn't
interest me so
um my interest is uh yeah and and just
trying to understand what is going on
and trying to do it in a way that's
human and not left or right but sort of
Center I guess and
um it's not you know it it doesn't
it doesn't necessarily fit with the
times sometimes but to me that's what I
can do to try to help to try to help on
the polarization to try to help on on
bias and and misinformation
um
you know it's important that like facts
actually matter and think there are
things which are true and there are
things which are not true and you can we
can actually go and see the things which
are true and we can tell you about the
things that are true and we can show you
the things that are not true
um you know I've interviewed people who
believe I drink the blood of children
and and am secretly a lizard
um and you know the former president
United States is catering to those
people like that they're all still out
there and I mean they literally believe
I drink the blood of children and uh
you know
I'm not you know I I don't know what to
do with that you know
um so yeah uh you know we live in a time
it's interesting to me that the more
information we have access to the more
this has bubbled up and the more this
digital information has spread you know
people can find out what is true you
know there's people believe that Joe
Biden is a sock puppet
um you know it's the same people who
believe I'm a lizard person so
um
it's uh yeah
um I just I you know I feel like I can
do what I can do and and I just don't
it's easy to get sucked into all that
other stuff because there's a market
incentive clearly for these other
networks to do that
um but it's just not something that I
personally am interested in so
or believe in so we're not going to
leave it there okay that would not be
okay okay
um so so why don't we end by asking what
are your future projects so you have the
aster book that's going to finish out
and what what else are you saying I need
another project is this is this you're
adding to my my stress here
um okay let me help you so no so look so
I work yeah I I do CNN uh I do 10
stories a year for 60 minutes and
um so yeah to me 60 Minutes is sort of
you know uh is is uh it's a show I've
grown up watching and
um
yeah I would I don't know what I guess
I'm doing another season of the podcast
and uh I don't know I hate I sound like
I'm pitching products I don't know I do
stuff I don't like I don't really know
where my career is going I don't know
what comes down the pike but um yeah I
what I like is being able to just to
work in all these different Realms and
and thankfully I'm in a place where you
know I can do the show on CNN I can do
60 minutes and I can you know I was just
in Cambodia for 60 minutes for uh for a
week of uh on a project an investigative
project I'm working on
um I just interviewed Rick Rubin this
really interesting music uh producer
who's you know just about every artist
you know has worked with him
um so I like dropping in on people's
very different than I would cover on CNN
but it's interesting to you know talk to
creative people and
yeah work work with them on those lines
am I correct that the Vanderbilt book is
going to be uh becoming a television
miniseries or something uh yeah I did uh
yeah they're uh wow you've done your
research there were uh yeah it's uh I
guess Amazon has uh picked it up for uh
to at least see a pilot for a possible
uh like dramatic series on it yeah we'll
see so
and the one that you critiqued in your
book with Angela Lansbury oh yeah so
when I was a kid uh so my mom was
involved with this custody battle when
she was 10 years old she was taken away
it was at the height of the depression
uh my mom had was uh it's so weird and
complicated to even go into but
basically my mom's mom uh and my mom's
great aunt Gertrude Vanderbilt Whitney
who created the Whitney Museum
um they sued for custody over my
ten-year-old mother
um neither of them really knew my mom
including her own mother but they both
sued for custody and it was called at
the time the trial of the century it was
these you know two well-known women
fighting for custody of this very rich
ten-year-old girl who was they called
little Gloria
um and the country was divided on it
hundreds of people would show up the
court every day it went on for months it
was you know my mom ultimately was taken
away from her own mother sent to with
Richard General Whitney because she was
the rich one and my mother was raised by
this Aunt who she didn't even know
um and how do we even get on this topic
a dramatized series
yeah but I don't know why I brought up
that oh no you brought up the Angelo
Landry thing anyway yes my mom never
talked about this experience she had as
a kid when I was a kid so I didn't
really know anything about it and then
one day some lady wrote a book about uh
about the custody battle Barbara
Goldsmith and it became a made for TV
mini series with Angela Lansbury and my
mom went ballistic because my mom had
never talked about this and it was like
deeply personal to her and all of a
sudden it's made for TV movie so
it was really fun the week that that TV
series was on uh to be in my house
because my mom was very upset um so yes
and it's terrible I I never saw it until
I wrote the venerable book and I finally
saw it and yeah it's really it's really
awesome you're very funny it's an
amazing story but uh it was done very
badly but yeah
so anyway and we'll be
uh it will be much much better than that
how many of you are undergraduates here
wow wow
and are you excited are you optimistic
about the world
yes yeah
I love you you said that you did that
the most sarcastically of anybody I've
ever you were like yeah
that's such a yell thing like yeah
you're optimistic but yeah just
sarcastically sorry
I get it
um some things don't change some things
don't change yeah well
um yeah I just think you know I just
remember
you know I just remember being at Yale
and being like scared of what was to
come and you know wishing I had a plan
and wishing
things were clearer and now and all the
things that I cared about at Yale at the
time
um I I you know I didn't really care so
much about classes I was I was a coxson
on a crew team I thought that to me that
was I was obsessed with it I look back
I'm like I don't know why I was so
obsessed with that
um but I was and all the things now that
I looked back fondly on are not the the
things I thought I would remember and
the things that I thought I would care
about all the things now they're it's
like little moments that I experienced
with friends and people on the team and
just these little moments that were
meaningless at the time
um but those are the things like I don't
I was on This Crew team and I don't
remember how we did we apparently did we
did very well I've been told
um but like I don't remember the races I
don't remember where we were in the
National you know championships and
stuff like that but I remember like
riding on the bus out to The Boathouse I
remember the creek on the stairs in The
Boathouse just these little things I
remember you know hanging out and Durfee
with my you know all my other loser
roommates you know and
all that stuff has taken on a much
greater import than when I was actually
going through it and so I guess I would
just say especially the person who's a
freshman is just to enjoy the experience
you're having and because what you're
going to remember of it is so different
than than what you think you're going to
remember of it and you're going to hear
like and it won't have any reality for
you until you're an old person like me
and coming back and you'll be like oh I
don't remember this but I remember the
ice cream at Durfee hall or whatever it
was you know anyway
that's it that's all I got all right
please join me in thanking Anderson
Cooper
[Music]